If you're a smoker trying to quit, boy do
you have options.
Patches, chewing gum, lollipops -- and even
lasers!
But if you're overwhelmed with choice, maybe
try nothing at all.
Hi aware citizens, Trace here for DNews.
Now smoking is bad for you -- it causes cancer
and a gazillion other diseases.
You know that.
We know that.
This is your life and we’re not going to
tell you what to do.
But we are going to tell you the science behind
quitting if you or someone you know is trying
to give up the habit.
Now before we breakdown the options, we have
to first understand why it’s so difficult
to quit in the first place.
One word: nicotine.
It’s what’s naturally found in tobacco
and as addictive as heroin and cocaine.
When inhaled, nicotine travels quickly to
the brain.
There, it releases dopamine and other feel
good chemicals into brain cell receptors.
This creates more and more nicotine receptors
in the brain.
When these receptors are starved of nicotine
you go through intense withdrawal, which can
lead to depression and tension, until you
get your next fix.
So the trick may be to gradually giving your
brain less and less nicotine, which is where
the highly advertized treatment of nicotine
replacement therapy comes into play.
We’re talking about patches, chewing gum,
lozenges, inhalers and even nasal spray and
lollipops.
But do these methods actually work?
Let’s take one of the most popular methods,
the patch.
This is typically a reservoir of nicotine
sandwiched between an occlusive and permeable
adhesive layers.
Stick it on your skin and the nicotine slowly
leaches through the layers of your dermis,
to the hypodermis, which contains blood vessels
needed to bring the drug into the bloodstream.
This happens at a much slower rate and at
a lower concentration than smoke inhalation.
Different patches contain different amounts
of nicotine, slowly ridding your body’s
dependence of the drug.
But is it effective?
Well, one study conducted by the Harvard School
of Public Health looked at 787 adults who
had recently quit smoking.
They were surveyed three different times over
the course of six years and asked questions
about what type of nicotine replacement therapy
they had used, the duration of the therapy,
if they had consulted a professional, and
their current smoking habits.
During each one of those check-ins around
a third of the participants had relapsed.
This led researchers to conclude that “using
nicotine replacement therapy is no more effective
in helping people stop smoking cigarettes
in the long-term than trying to quit on one’s
own.”
What about alternative ways to quit smoking?
Some people have tried acupuncture and hypnosis,
but based on some of our last videos, it’s
a little up for debate on whether that works
or not.
And others have even tried lasers.
Yes, lasers… well, low-level lasers therapy.
The company Innovative Laser Therapy claims
that an hour of therapy is all you’d need
to quit your addiction.
The lasers target specific points in the body
that the company alleges are related to addiction,
claiming it relieves withdrawal symptoms and
prevents cravings.
Owner Frank Pinto explains, “The laser basically
stimulates the nerve endings to tell the brain
to release a flood of endorphins.”
But “basically” isn’t science.
And though there have been a few studies to
determine its validity, they are few and far
between with inconclusive results.
But perhaps the best thing to do is nothing
at all.
In a 2016 study published in the journal Annals
of Internal Medicine, 697 adult smokers who
smoked at least 15 cigarettes a day were divided
into two groups: those who quit cold turkey
and those who gradually reduced their smoking
over the course of two weeks.
Researchers recorded their results both four
weeks then six months later.
Nearly half of the cold turkey group successfully
quit smoking after a month, compared to 39%
of those who gave it up gradually.
At the half-year mark, the rates of success
reduced to 22% and 15% respectively, but this
still means the cold turkey technique is still
more effective than gradual reduction.
Of course there are other factors that take
place when finding the right way to quit like
genetics and age.
So like many of our health related episodes,
it’s probably best to consult your doctor
on what’s right for you.
Quitting cigarettes is a great step towards
a more healthy lifestyle, and if that’s
your thing, you should definitely check out
Beachbody On Demand.
You can get access a wide variety of workout
programs including the world-famous P90X,
Insanity, Focus T25, and many others, ranging
from cardio to resistance training, yoga,
dance, low impact and more.
Sign up for Beachbody On Demand today and
get a FREE 30-Day Membership.
Smoking does a lot of crazy stuff to your
body, but when you do find that effective
way to quit, is that alone enough to reverse
all the damage done from smoking?
Tara talks about it more in this video.
Have you, or anyone you know, tried to quit
smoking?
What did you use?
Did it work?